you come and get it oh here we go it's
so great having you here North I've
always wanted a brother to throw to yeah
now I have two big brothers to look out
for me hey
oh my God that is you Scarlett that's
doing your first movie
we had a feeling you might react because
we saw the talent there great movie by
the way yeah great movement 94 almost 30
years ago
from the very distant past guess what
since then you've become and this is
true the highest grossing actress of all
time that's an incredible fact yes oh
really yes yes and Scarlett Johansson
stars in director Wes Anderson's newest
movie It's called asteroid City it's a
story that follows attendees at a star
gazer Convention as their lives converge
in a desert town in 1955. Johansen plays
Midge Campbell and the icon yes
hello
we met before I'm the mother of that
cookie Trooper who idolizes you I know
that you might not recognize me out of
uniform
you're very good in the one about the
in the brothel who gets amnesia
and become a pediatrician you are very
awesome actually maybe my favorite
character ever I don't know why nobody
else liked it oh yes me neither thank
you some people liked it oh I'm sure I
did some people a lot of people didn't
like it a lot of people like this as
well Scarlett Johansson joins us now
first on CBS mornings thank you very
much for being here yes for having me uh
the world of asteroid city is so bizarre
but amazing at the same time and I love
spending what 90 minutes two hours in it
uh and your character Midge uh is unique
movie icon which you are as well highest
grossing actors of all time what was it
like going from real movie icon into
this version of it
um it was I I really loved playing Midge
Campbell she is
um a you know movie star she is someone
who is used to being in the spotlight
she's very comfortable taking long
Clauses and just letting it all you know
kind of settle um she's she's not in a
rush you helped create the role with Wes
what does that mean well well you know I
I I mean I got the script from Wes I was
actually during uh the whole kind of
shutdown lockdown
um so I was pretty thrilled to be
getting anything to read at all felt
like a hopeful something
um and you know it's the the film is
very the story is very complex and so I
had a lot of questions about I'm playing
an actor playing an actor preparing a
role and who is Mitch Campbell what kind
of you know what is her reality what
kind of a movie star is she and so we
sort of settled on a kind of Betty Davis
type you know that that sort of
illustrious career you know it's got
that kind of presence about it so a
couple times Scarlett don't be upset but
I got confused a little bit as I was
watching yeah confusing flash over you
yeah yeah I mean I look at the cast
because it's Tom Hanks it's Steve Carell
it's Brian Cranston star studded tonnage
of talent is amazing that was also part
of the fun for me was watching who's
gonna pop up next and then you know to
figure out what the storyline was do you
think it's supposed to be kind of
circusy in a way was it it is it's a
little bit of it so it's not just me no
it's definitely
um you know I think it's a it's a kind
of
screenshot into Wes's brain now you know
I think it's very much a culmination of
his career where he's at in his life
um you know it was something that we
came out of the quarantine time as well
so you see some of that reflected in the
film it is it's sort of a existential
film I would say
um do you have fun doing it I loved
doing it and when you talk about all the
incredible talent in it you know we
really worked in this bubble which is
how Wes likes to work anyway and so we
all stayed in this
um in this kind of in together and the
whole place was locked down so you know
at any moment you'd see like Willem
Dafoe at the cappuccino maker running on
the treadmill and Jeff Goldblum be on
the StairMaster it was really surreal
and amazing that's amazing yeah the
movie's also still and amazing uh on
this show Nate Burleson over here he
makes a lot of jokes funny guy I do a
lot of laughing also sometimes with the
compliments he's a little over the top a
little cringe right so cringing but I've
been laughing it's 90 laughing it leads
to some lines on my face you can see can
you help Scarlet I can't he had a one
year anniversary here skincare line yes
yeah yes it's our one year anniversary
of the outset
um yes it is a my my passion project is
it um it is it is I um worked for five
years developing this skincare line and
I had
acne prone skin growing up in all my 20s
I know because I use the outsole yeah I
really do um and it's through that like
process of just you know trial and error
where I discovered okay if I can you
know if I can just let my skin heal
itself I mean it was before we knew
about the Skin Barrier and all of that
stuff and I just started using really
gentle products that brought the
moisture back into my face and that's
when my skin started healing itself and
that is what the outset is all about so
it is I have a I have an expression line
cream for you oh lovely there you go
when my wife found out this was
happening though she wanted uh to see if
you have any samples of the firming
vegan collagens yes I definitely know
that that is yeah that's our that's our
best seller really I use it all like I
use it all day actually my boyfriend's
addicted to it in addition to your skin
care line because I want a bottle of
that too what does it mean when you hear
you that you were the highest grossing
actress of all time is that come with a
belt or like a mug I'm pretty sure I'm
gonna get some text message from Sam
Jackson that'll be like no no no no no
wait a minute
um yes he's I think he's the number one
oh I guess I'm the maybe actress yeah
the actress but I will say you have you
have Tom Hanks uh beat according to the
numbers so that's something you bring up
with him I'm going to start doing that
now I'm going to touch them now let's
see how he feels about it before we let
you go I have to ask about marriage your
husband Colin Jones yes if you can't
give some advice mom Rose's mom what
would you say is the secret to a good
successful healthy marriage oh my gosh I
don't profess to know anything about
that but I will say I
and we always you know we communicate
with one another and check in you know
I'm married to a writer he's a comedy
writer he can get like very in his head
sometimes he's sort of introverted I'm X
extroverted obviously and so I think the
key for us is just always checking in
and you know ass at the end of the day
how was your day's gonna go black
afterwards the movie take a look at it
we'll see